with big hero 6 out now let's take a
look at 15 things you probably didn't
know about Disney's animated hits the
design of baymax in space which is two
dots joined by a line was inspired by
the look of Japanese Suzu bells which
director Don Hall came across on a visit
to Japan the huggable design of
healthcare robot baymax was inspired by
director Don Hall's visit to Carnegie
Mellon University where he spent time
with researchers working on soft
robotics such as an inflatable vinyl arm
that could perform simple tasks like
brushing someone's teeth according to
lead character designers Shi Yoon Kim
the design of baymax is also influenced
by Japanese infomercials which often
highlight a product's cute design rather
than its technology when it came to
making baymax move the animators looked
at real robots movie robots babies and
even koala birds for inspiration but in
the end they found that the way baby
penguins moved was the best fit for
baymax the reason for this was that baby
penguins have similar body proportions
the big hero 6 robots in other words
they've got long torsos and short legs
when it came to bringing baymax to life
the keyword for the big hero 6 artist
was restrained because baymax is a robot
and has limited movements it was
important to keep the animation minimal
and separate out movements so for
example baymax walks forward and then he
waves in fact rather than animating
baymax the artists referred to their
work as animating him and as they max
doesn't have a mouth or human facial
expressions the artists had to find ways
to capture quick and easily readable
poses for example how much he moved his
head or blinked his eyes big hero 6
averages more main characters on screen
at any one time than in any previous
movie by Walt Disney Animation Studios
for the artists behind big hero 6 for
looking for inspiration for chewing gum
popping daredevil gogo Tomago whose
catchphrase is woman up they looked at
actors such as John Wayne
eastwood and gary cooper to city they're
cool emotionally reserved traits they
also looked at bike messengers and speed
skaters to inform go-go's body type and
movements director Don Hall got the idea
for the superhero suit worn by laid-back
comic-book fan Fred when he saw online
videos of people dressed in Cajun
costumes having wrestling matches
Fred's fire-breathing super suit
includes claws integrated communications
and a super bounce hundreds of
background characters populate the world
of San fransokyo to make the city feel
believable those characters are more
detailed and varied than ever before
coming in all different shapes sizes
cultures and fashions the big hero six
artists use a software called denizen
which was created by Walt Disney
Animation Studios to create and animate
the crowds with this tech the artist
created 670 unique characters compared
to 270 unique characters in frozen 185
in wreck-it Ralph and 80 in Tangled
each of those 670 unique characters in
big hero 6 has up to 32 different
clothing look combinations plus 32
different hair and skin tones all of
which means the big hero 6 filmmakers
could have 686 thousand and 80 unique
characters in San fransokyo Walt Disney
animated Studios encourage their
employees to include themselves as
background characters in big hero 6
which means that the movies crowd scenes
feature cameos from 200 Walt Disney's
animated Studios employees the city of
San fransokyo were big hero 6 takes
place maybe a fictional mashup of San
Francisco and Tokyo but the creation of
that fictional world began with real
world geography not only did the
filmmakers take research trips to both
San Francisco and Tokyo but the movies
artists also use actual maps of San
Francisco including the layout of the
streets and the size of the Lots as a
blueprint to give their city and
authentic look in addition to that real
data the artists incorporated the visual
style of Tokyo's architecture its neon
lights and signage
and stylized everything to make it
unique to San fransokyo San fransokyo
features over 80,000 buildings a hundred
thousand vehicles over two hundred
thousand streetlights and over 250
thousand trees the labs that the San
fransokyo Institute of Technology were
inspired by research trips the big hero
16 made several US universities
including Harvard and MIT and also to
Pasadena Jet Propulsion lab to help make
the movies big finale relate to
real-world research the filmmakers
consulted theoretical physicist Sean
Carroll who does research at Caltech on
cosmology field theory gravity and
quantum mechanics director Don Hall's
kids have been pitching him sequel ideas
of big hero six and they particularly
love to see ninja baymax come out of the
portal to fight good baymax well there
you have it 15 things you probably
didn't know about big hero 6 now tell me
what would you love to see in a big hero
6 sequel if you enjoyed this video hit
the thumbs up button and subscribe for
more things you didn't know and weekly
movie reviews and interviews thanks for
watching yippee-ki-yay movie lovers